- vacth nous recevons maintenant madame
françoise giroud vous avez été
interpellé madame vous avez entendu dans
une finale tout à l'heure et jacques
disait il faut dès que des personnalités
européennes ddd personnel politique ou
pas puis je prendre position car déjà
que nous sommes inquiets sur le sort
d'un certain nombre de deux d'enfants
qui sont prisonniers dans une école de
police et bien cela vous avez en savoir
un peu plus mais si ce que suggère
merlino est exact on a vraiment envie de
crier au gouvernement algérien pas ça et
pas vous cet intérêt table est ce que
vous pourriez imaginer de demander vous
et quelques autres intellectuels
je dis encore une fois le personnalités
politiques et non politique
une mission pour aller voir si les
choses se passent eux conformément aux
droits de l'homme par exemple est-ce que
c'était envisageable se passer c'est la
forme que ça va prendre du temps il faut
certainement en effet demandé des
éclaircissements pour le moins très bien
madame nous vous recevons jaillir pour
deux raisons aujourd'hui à propos de ce
livre que vous présentez que vous
commentez qui est publié chez carré ça
s'appelle les femmes de la révolution
2006 mais aussi vous êtes la femme de
communication ça serait bien dommage de
ne pas parler de ça avec vous juste un
petit mot sur sur le comité d'experts
qui a réfléchi donc fait partie qui va
qui a réfléchi bien à une nouvelle haute
autorité de l'audiovisuelle bon alors
quels pouvoirs supplémentaires doit doit
se donner ce nouveau conseil
il en fait un pouvoir de sanction à ce
qui n'est pas négligeable à l'égard des
déchets et qui ne respecteront pas tout
qui ne respecteront pas et des
engagements qu'elles ont trait c'est à
dire marquer comme on a comme on dit les
cahiers des charges et d'après vous pour
donner un exemple si une chaîne
commerciale
on va dire tf1 ouazar sur son cahier des
charges est remarqué doit faire de la
création française
et si elle veut pas en faire beaucoup
n'ont cessé plus précis que ça c'est à
dire elle doit faire tant de l on a fait
moins où elle a passé plus de publicité
qu'elle n'a le droit à une série
d'actions que fait le conseil là et il
dit quoi il a payé comme en commune i il
peut intervenir de plusieurs manières il
peut punir avec des amendes salées
souverainement c'est vrai dès ce vous
savez c'est assez bon parfois ça peut
aller très loin elle s'appelle et
jusqu'à la suspension d'antenne très
bien mais alors dans ce cas le ministère
de la communication de madame tasca a
t-il sa raison d'être à vous bien sûr
c'est autre chose
je crois que l'instance en question doit
être ce qu'on appelle une instance de
régulation c'est à dire un gendarme
c'est ça et s'assurer de la circulation
et la bonne circulation des choses dans
ce domaine bien parce que vous
conseillez à propos du secteur public
que nous y sommes là est ce que vous
vous conseiller au secteur public de
continuer à avoir une part de de
publicité dans son budget ou pas je
souhaiterais qu'elle soit beaucoup plus
faible
il est évident qu'une influence de la
publicité sur la nature de la production
n'est pas excellente et que 65 ans 67 %
s'agissant des as 2 oui je crois que
c'est trop oui cela dit il nous faudra
des sous bien sûr les apprenants même
beaucoup et nous avons amendé et
pourquoi pas dit mise en contre à l'état
l'état subventionne le paiera à l'état
subventionne le théâtre l'état soutient
de cinéma l'état soutient à 13 pourquoi
est ce que l'état n'interviendrait pas
ne participerez pape ou une peur à la
télévision publique un conditions de
cette aide est venue dire public soit à
la hauteur de ce qu'on attend d'elle
diane en disent bien entendu vous avez
dit récemment dans une interview à notre
confrère libération a eu des propos très
durs
vous avez parlé des fleurs 3 en disant
que échec sanglant
c'est un boulet alors qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire de cette chaîne faut-il
associer à antenne 2 ça c'est vraiment
un problème trop grave pour que je vous
demande en gros ce qu'il faut trouver
une solution pour elle et pour elle seul
ou faut-il associer antenne 2
éventuellement je ne serai pas
personnellement pour une association
parce que je crois que l'un des deux
entraîneurs l autre et ce ne serait pas
souhaité enfin vraiment c'est un
problème compliqué qui concerne une
quantité de gens 3000 personnes qui sont
anxieux tout à fait légitimement
encontre à leur avenir et quant à
l'avenir de leur chaîne on ne peut pas
en parler comme ça en 30 secondes alors
on se reverra donc on vous invitera pour
parler de l'odieux
alors maintenant revenu en forme de la
révolution ces femmes de la révolution
un mot pour situer ce monsieur me chier
quand même vous écoutez monsieur michel
c'est un homme formidable
ce nom est un peu poussiéreux comme ça
quand elles entendent y envoyer un grand
historien ce tassement mais pas du tout
il écrit avec une verve avec une passion
extraordinaire
il sait tout et il a fait ce livre d'une
façon assez amusante parce que pour
finir il avait besoin d'argent ils
étaient éliminés du collège de france
par le peu de contrat et il s'est dit je
vais sortir de mon histoire de la
révolution tout ce qui concerne les
femmes
ce soir je vais mettre ça boutabout une
petite sauce au début une petite source
à la fin de la ligne mais c'est ce qu'il
a fait est très bien
c'était un homme très aimée je crois au
moment de son de son enterrement
il y avait énormément des milliers de
parisiens ont vu arriver à son inter
donc son savant acculèrent c'est le
premier grand historien républicain est
censé voir et était bien divulgué donc
plus vite alors dont il a fait un cours
au collège de france sur les flammes et
ça se voit dans ce livre parce que les
femmes de la révolution il y en a de
toutes sortes vous savez il ya déjà des
images et des personnages en tout genre
mais chacune a droit à une part de son
père et on le sent et c'est ce qui fait
la valeur et la qualité et l'intérêt
solide mais bon il est pas un peu comme
on dit un peu machiste monsieur michel
mathys pas d'histoire de journaux et la
vision des femmes un peu particulier
parce qu'elles sont mieux comme postière
que comme une femme d'état ça c'est sûr
mais il n'est pas ma suisse et par le
génie mort des femmes est ce que j'ai
moi essayer de faire puisque je suis pas
l'auteur du livre ce que je peux vous en
parler avec mes deux passions ses deux
de remettre tous les portraits qu'il
fait qu'ils vont de charlotte corday
manon roland théroigne de méricourt etc
les remettre dans le contexte de la
révolution de rappeler ce qu'étaient
l'histoire autour et sur tout ce qui a
été l'histoire des féministes de la
révolution est une histoire toujours
escamoté or il y en a eu
les femmes en fait n'ont rien gagné avec
la révolution
elles ont gagné le divorce bonaparte le
rendez tout de suite
elles ont gagné l'égalité des droits des
parents sur les enfants ont le leur
enlever
très rapidement il n'est rien resté de
la révolution dont les femmes
spécifiquement il aurait resté ce que
bon dieu qui n'est pas négligeable
liberté égalité fraternité
merci madame je renvoie les lecteurs
donc ceux qui sont intéressés par notre
histoire l'histoire de france et
l'histoire des femmes qui ont fait cette
grande histoire des canards majuscule
ça s'appelle les femmes de la révolution
s'est donc présenté et commenté par
françoise géraud essai publié aux
éditions car elle est bien